hello good morning good morning I'm Eric
that's Rob I'm sorry dropping in so
we're just gonna I'm gonna move this
picture picture that's fine Eric let's
just preface all this by saying this is
my first drop I haven't played
battlefield in a very long time so
people need to do their best to not hate
my gameplay and my skills because it's
been a while it's all good baby I'm here
for you so we're talking about
battlefield fives
battle royale firestorm it is out today
as Rob mentioned is the first time he's
played now Dave Jewett did get to check
out the game more recently he also got a
victory a squad victory so if you want
to check that out you can case watch
calm and youtube.com slash GameSpot
thank you for tuning in on a Monday
morning to GameSpot live we're live
Monday to Friday checking out cool games
fun games recurring games games that we
love and we like hanging out with all of
y'all to check them out all right Rob
how's it feel back in the back in the
saddle
after playing so much apex damn there's
fuel in this game yes okay so the
vehicles yeah you know more than me I
feel like I know a little bit so the
vehicles as part of like the balancing
of the vehicles right is that your
teammates have to continuously like fuel
it to kind of keep it running which
makes sense right and the other
interesting thing I think that Dave was
talking about is just the how vehicles
come into play and just like how like
and when you want to use them to some
degree because like you know barrel
Rogalla in some capacity you could argue
is you know you kind of want to sneak
right like you don't really want to be
seen and having a vehicle basically
tells everyone like oh hey by the way
guys here's a king who you oh yeah gnar
more huh all right good good first try
oh you're doing solo right so you can do
solo yes I won't be squads I think all
right man let's try some squads out then
we'll go back to solo oh that's that's
another interesting thing there that's
different from bad arouses they'd like
the
just forgot about battlefield 5
destructible environments there's blue
game-changers you know you can't just
can't just hide in a house you know
necessarily without getting bomba teared
all right good warm-up match sleeves are
rolled up yeah I do want to play again
let's do squad all right let's try it so
yeah you got helicopters prototype
helicopters as they explained it because
helicopters weren't that pronounced in
World War two in fact I think there were
like barely any cases I'm just recon
probably recall yeah so it looked like
there are some so they're there mod
attachments to right I want to say I
picked up like a I accept like a grenade
launcher on for a weapon
oh nice I actually haven't played either
I've only kind of seen a little bit of
our footage I know some things but you
know we'll do our best
I just knew it was out I was like oh we
should check out firestorm yeah but you
know our firestorm experts in the UK and
he's also sick I was gonna actually have
him try squad up with us but then I
think he's he's proper sick so where he
is he is bedridden and so I'm told
Filip a words is seen enough back to
apex man give it a go I think um it
could be interesting I this wait time
though is a well sus little suss but
it's okay you know we're halfway there
oh you know what I should be moving us
to the top right huh it'd be cool yet
operates better I think it'd be cool to
about a minute not terrible
considering it's like looking for a full
squad for you like three other members
what we gonna say sorry I cut you off
terrible host
oh I don't know it'd be cool to like
mess with your armory or your company
while waiting for a match the the
loading room is pretty cool I like that
like that oh yeah yeah it's kind of neat
got some old-timey music mr. J is that
no right there's no way that some
Rockets slide on a rad remember uh
Facebook producer well anyone can be mr.
J cuz it's just like the Joker but here
you go your your squadmates and they'll
look he likes it get stabbed
oh is eyeball you see the eye twitch
like season one eye is just like pretty
cool it's pretty cool what eyeball
[Music]
like I'm up head there for a second oh
yeah ooh cockroaches to your inventory
that's pretty cool like that it's not
like it's not like full screen like I
think that's kind of nice good so it
doesn't like obstruct your view
pre-ground is pretty long though
yeah get that ammo alright so they let
ya I let you pick stuff up in the UH
that's come here yes conduit and it's a
little frustrating now if you lose it's
a little frustrating the fact that like
I had it I had to load in to my squad
and then load into this pre-round
it's not ideal right like I should be in
a match by now I'm on it you want to be
able to get in and out quick you want to
be able to forget the last match right
back you know a new one drop spicy oh
this parts cool oh that's cool I didn't
see this just now while we were setting
up so it says it needs 100 players so it
looks like 63 could be around 60 ish
chat is going to shite I can't get rid
of some folks if we need to but I mean
the way I view it is I can't read what
they're writing so it's probably fine I
also like this I think it's cool to see
that the ring kind of just on the
outskirts and it's coming in I think
crime had mentioned earlier it's like
pretty sick to like drive away from one
of those oh nice okay so he wants to
jump there it's kind of hard to tell I
guess I'll leave now
yeah so what's the strategy here do we
dive like others no I'm so you still
apex like 145 135 just drop already well
we are we got to go with our squad man
we're playing squads right now you want
to succeed you need to be with your
squad
do you deploy that yourself or did I
just had applied I'm gonna be why
certain earlier if I needed to but I
don't know why you would all right we're
free looking trying to make sure there's
no trouble there's a dude mister yeah
nice today
alright so five minutes to start a game
roughly I think it's like you're my you
know your mileage may vary depending on
your situation if you have a full squad
already maybe that loads things in
drastically yep shuttle little med pack
I guess you already had a shovel melee
duh oh boy it's gonna be a learning
experience late Maul back ok so I guess
you can repair armor with the armor
plates which is kind of like blackout
now your chap so I could like jump do
that I guess not all right keep looting
got to keep looting is there a ping
system at all that's a good question I
don't think so I think more games in
general just need to adopt the ping
system if someone in chat knows if there
is a ping system crime my boy help us
out just just crime play battlefield I
think he played something yeah he's
telling me about his experience
Gammage that says it's pretty fun but it
needs some improvements well not bad if
that's the case to start off hopefully
you know they'll probably continue to
support it and and add hopefully some
features and things like that tell Rob
to expect campers oh yeah I'm spare it's
battle royale I mean you can you also
can like well 1897 you can you can go
prone in this game right like that's
that's that's a warrior's delight right
there I don't know a battlefield all to
me was a little bit slow Oh mr. Jays got
armor you know X gon give it to you I
mean he should be ooh
you see so this is like that risk reward
right you got your turret you're good
but then people know that you're like
you know moseying about now we're kind
of curious how like the vehicles is
probably where it'll be the biggest
difference right for Battle Royale just
because people have to deal with it you
get the advantage of it or disadvantage
depending on how you look at it kind of
insane NAB's pretty big - it feels like
well that's been looted where's that
someone's been here well I mean there is
spotting right kind of which remember
that was queue everyone saying queue to
ping Oh sick thank you yeah yeah you can
appreciate very much guys I mean we both
have oh we're in front of you
yeah that's what you get wait did you
kill yeah you gotta kill sick alright go
go finish him for his loot right get out
oh say we got our vehicle kill safe
thank you uh shadow play Nvidia Oh
little GeForce experience listen to us Q
there's a little bit of a delay oh sorry
sorry sorry y'all I appreciate it I
appreciate all of you guys thank you so
much for helping us out
just be patient I should you know what
I'm gonna start setting the YouTube
stream to that intermediate mode where
chat is more like less the late I need
to remember to do that it is an option
so we will do that in the future
apologies games pretty oh it's always
been a very good looking game yeah
that's for sure and I had some fun with
um five a little bit you know I'm
traditionally not a BF player so oh this
is one of those sick of Infinia
combinations much of a range here that's
weird though why are you getting drop
effects on your face yeah like a mask on
it's just my eyes gonna water my eyes so
I got a little I guess an armor
he's like buddy we're gonna go Thompson
I'll swap town Thompson got a shotgun
so chat I need more help there's an
armor plate only repair armor or can he
use that too like oh this is better
increases like actual armor like I
actually gave himself armor either what
is this new apex Legends mod who knows
let's call it apex legends with vehicles
oh can I drop this yeah okay cool
it scared me right so green okay
everyone's got to start out as a private
yeah
oh you're you gained fifty experience
because it's 932 alive dude I have such
an urge to slide right now sniper over
here no you and I both know where that's
gonna lead Oh medium backpack that's
better than small no no I'm sorry I I
was uh sorry my uh yeah was more of like
a UH it's not fair I I just wish that
was more evident other than having to
like stare at it I guess I guess the
backpack was bigger though armor adds to
health basically well you're looking at
color code - right so like I'm green
says to run faster kind of like apex
while running jump and midair Crouch to
slide and you will continue you will
continue when you fall and then run and
repeat
I don't know crying oh no I'm I'm doing
it right something we're gonna have to
work on the mode maintain that momentum
hi we'd like some armor
it adds to health but the amount depends
on the on your armor so it's basically
like a fax yeah but this he needs to
find actual armor though right like the
armor scrap that he got is just probably
to repair armor I would assume health is
what are we doing my armor I think right
yeah and your boys got on when my boys
were they at what are they doing up here
gunfire I also heard footsteps somewhere
did you yeah well that's an armor plate
so you just build up bits of armor on
your [ __ ] my logic said dictates that
whoa whoa I'll take that is that it's
kind of like black where you repair with
it but you can jump out of the window by
pressing jump don't you try that though
I don't know if this well that one this
was you can use it right now it's as
savage the armor plating does that
actually do anything there you go oh
boom there you go
so you swapped out a piece of armor so
you're good so you gained health by
doing that sick thank you to everyone
helping us out appreciate it
so I just use it once yeah yeah so
you're good look at your health that's
all I get
it's like an extra layer maybe also mr.
J just got two bars so maybe he got a
higher of a better armor scrap it's kind
of like apex I would assume where
there's different tiers of arm where the
one you have is common okay gotcha
okay cool we are learning evolving I'm
like a balloon that is a balloon oh you
think I don't know if it's the same it's
a resupply point so like if you capture
it you get stuff okay that's cool so
it's like a point of interest and I
guess if you can hold it long and
that yeah just relaxing chilling all
right that's cool I like I like that
there's these like little like areas um
I guess they're cut maybe these are the
equivalent of like drops oh is that a
person that dropped yeah or maybe maybe
that's know or like it looks like
they're yeah it could be a care package
or something
awk star over here I wish I was that you
read where'd that dude this is something
drop a this guy Oh superior operational
service saved try grab this it's a level
2 sniper for my shotgun I don't know
that's up to you
this is a better shotgun right maybe
yeah
oh is that an RPG yeah that's alright
alright so yeah seems like once you get
a supply I didn't even see this stuff
drop it just like spilled it out like
alright doesn't have to make sense it's
mine I think he wants me to pick this up
you can capture but other people can see
you captured yeah yeah that's why I
think it's cool because it's like oh oh
they're coming on yeah yeah through the
bridge oh I'm gonna pick us up Rob's
hot-swap in mid-fight I like it oh it's
kind of goddamn Emma that's why no
problem dynamite
are your armors kind of cracked
teammates bleeding out that's also bad
oh we smoke house a sniper wasn't it
dude snipers are clutching this you
gotta get that oh you can machete him Oh
God
good luck rob a car 98 make sense that's
cool
926 not bad I want more so yeah
definitely risk/reward there because
they probably knew that we were
capturing this the supply point so they
probably came over yeah that makes sense
crime set is one of the useful items at
the last circles to have a spotting
flare take one if you can find one
repair your armor too late that's always
the other thing I struggle with at least
with them other be ours is like is now
the time to repair I guess you did have
cover and they weren't spamming grenade
so I guess you could have but whatever
every time you pick a drop gun you're
supposed for you're supposed to reload
on my cut there so I just I the sniper
at the sniper I picked up I just need to
reload it oh is that what it is I guess
I don't know this is make sense I guess
yeah they rate that's - that's stuff
like that that makes picking up a weapon
yeah you don't want a hot swap then yeah
maybe that balances out some stuff I
don't know so you can repair any armor
no matter what I think it's more that
let's not like on you right yeah and
then I think like depending on the metal
plates that you get I think it just
gives you more but you can put it on if
you have them it's it so it's but it's
so it still operates as a consumable
consumable right like yeah I don't take
up armor I don't I can't just like
continually repair it I believe so okay
or maybe you just start off with like
the the level 1 armor so to speak and
then you get stuff that you can pick up
to then consume it but then maybe
there's a higher tier of armor that you
can get right
this game does feel a little hardcore I
like it I know you went from zero to 100
to zero well he had a little bit of
armor that sniper killed him but he
probably had shot him
oh for sure though it felt like someone
else the guy was shooting at me wasn't
yeah I think the guy that you were
aiming at first I was at behind cover
was probably the sniper yeah
all right if you have plates you can
replace a broken line yeah so is there
like tiers of armor then I know you guys
are like I saw mr. Jay had a level two
armor so to speak is that something they
found whoa what's that like epic or
something let's start it's got a bipod
I'm gonna look on it okay so it's got
its level three whatever rating that is
oh it's got perks yeah so bipod I mean I
wish I would know anyway these were so
small I mean you're supposed to know
right that's kind of rough you can find
blue looking or purple the best looking
place okay so it's plates it's all plate
related though okay quick scope BAM MLG
420 no scopes got a plane this is a
paratrooper plan good you because 52 you
would know more about planes that I do
oh there's another purple or pink item
over there right above you
the 42 this is a semi on I'm gonna get
the ammo because you're out of it okay
so do guns all start with no ammo do
they that's interesting oh yeah that's
right that looks like it shreds we need
one of those yeah then we'll win higher
armor more plates you can add ah okay
gotcha so you just got to get a higher
armor that you can then put more plates
into but it probably comes with the
plates and then you can prepare what
play it's got it okay that makes a lot
of sense thank you all for your tips and
patience as we are checking out
firestorm for the first time or Rob is
I'm just here to kind of like hey you're
checking it out to get up you're
learning right now you're on you're in
out in on this well my brain has been
off today Carson's also the map is weird
there's a stone Shen like place and it
plays strange music nearby so there's
like points of various points of
interest that are like Easter Egg II
maybe wonder how bad the firestorm hurts
look like you can mean just like any
circle like you know John you you just
have to loot wouldn't get there that
it's like more of like a shooting range
in the beginning there go up get where
get why I can't say you were you were
it's a really good gun yeah it is I
don't know what I used every time I
played battlefield 5 was like it was
that SMG it was it
remember that medic gun we we were like
yeah that was that is that like the the
single-shot yeah okay yeah yeah yeah I
always use an SMG because I was trying
to play it like Cod which is not a good
idea I was running and gunning baby yeah
really good max go last this is any fun
I don't know this is a learning
experience for me so I'd like to keep at
it I bet so far it's but it's it's
intriguing yeah oh that's a dude did
anyone on my team land with me well go
loot
yeah good call yeah that's why you're
here armor okay good good good good
are we good we at least got was that
like a STG or something yeah oh that
one's got a scope Oh turn up gameplay I
heard that blue I heard their footsteps
oh look at this look at it look at Rob
learning putting that armor plate on
right away she crouched to take that
this gun looks legit where's that guy I
want you to light him up like a
Christmas tree I know
footsteps feel so loud I want you to
make a big play out the window but
scooch did you notice I can shut my fo
because I'm a gamer Oh fov does help ya
guys over here right oh man oh yeah yeah
I think you can hear that blue house
here right I can get in this car yeah I
know
do you watch you I mean if I want to
move can I use this now that's a level
two no no you didn't pick oh I just
picked up a plate do you want that gun
the p40 - yeah let's let's matter so
it's a level 2 gun I'll mess with it oh
it's got the double it's got that weird
double scope don't know how I feel about
that I'm G and a rifle so probably I'll
just killing look beside the map there's
no one on your team your solo drop oh
yeah
the mic stand is also blocking
let's look for trouble I guess wanted
someone with yeah yes they're still
squabbling what's this
artillery strike flare gun you can call
it a strike yo let's do that dude dude
are you Gibraltar stop I'll give you
salt is legit man well level oh no you
know I know yeah I thought the same
thing too ooh you got a better armor
plate thing nope we gotta make sure we
get such a strike dog we got out we got
a side bust we got a third party agree
if all we get is like a double kill
artillery strike that'll be worth worth
everything double man I'm looking for
I'll kill you gotta kill already oh I
know but with this arch oh sorry I'm
ambitious I guess it's four okay oh you
can get a v1 rocket yeah how is that
fair like what are you supposed to aim
and war ain't fair dude yeah I mean
you're not wrong frag grenade rifle okay
so that's like another Jesus there's so
many weapons I know right - I can't be -
because you're on your SMG for - you're
right so I have to equip it or is it
it's a your backpack oh so you can carry
extra gun
I guess you hot spot that we see a
vehicle maybe or something are you
you're in the circle right yeah we
sitting pretty we're the action that
we're looking to shoot this our flare
gun off use the artillery to lure
enemies away that's what I would do
shall we oh I scared me
we're using it to kill people the v1 is
Opie here I could imagine that being
the case this is the gun I add in the in
the loading or the hangar I heard
something my footsteps are kind of like
they're your footsteps yeah I can see
what you're saying though it's kind of
like delayed almost yeah yeah put it in
the high low oh that door open yeah yeah
we got trouble I think they heard
they're gone no my guess unless they're
camping like crime said camping in the
house
you could be upstairs Rob I've got to be
careful check your corners you would
have died already if he was there I
think unless he just says betting he or
she has bet him
watch where zambese oh no okay oh those
are footsteps I think that was a flag Oh
was it
Oh was that okay it sounded like what's
that but if it was a flag that makes a
lot of sense resupply point under attack
where we got a truck Hey
oh you're right near it hey should I go
there yeah yeah yeah drop the artillery
on the repo it's - you're right on the
respawn or the resupply you know what I
mean they want they want that resupply
we got a guy they're gonna spaz we got a
little flare gun action for you you know
I don't even know how this works
but we're about to find out just be
careful they're probably like sitting on
it you know so what should I try to do
it right where I want you to flare gun
II I don't know what the hell it does
[Music]
they gotta be there right oh we might
get artillery come on come on baby come
on baby
nothing oh come on give me a winner I
still hear the tank that's not good oh
not good cha Chi I like it I like it I
like it though oh look at how close it
is to blowing up and
I don't even know that close oh he's
like a dude so close three get three
health left oh he would have died he
would have had all his buddies down I
didn't I did that all right
sex for them dang that was close that
was it that was it cool I like that that
was fun I think if the difference here
in the shine or the word this game could
shine is that the vehicle stuff I think
and like dealing with vehicles yeah
shucks that was close that would have
been really cool if you got a double
kill on the tank oh we need to probably
bring out that frag grenade thing or
something kind of fire that thing off
maybe yeah that's a good point I ship
kept going dang it hindsight that's all
right too many things to remember yes we
already that artillery strike was pretty
good that's pretty big spread that was
dope almost had him almost I mean yeah I
should have used that grenade like
because what else was I gonna do against
a tank you know unload your clip and
hope for the best
play uh pull a Miller from Provo Ryan
colt is all I got left
FIFA p-51 sir tank Buster's angels on
the sky yeah a good life Ernest the
other day good often hasn't seen it oh
really yeah enjoy it yeah it holds up I
think oh my god yeah you know the thing
is is it's like all practical effect mmm
like there's only like one or two shots
like the actual landing you see like the
balloons and stuff but like the movies
like all practically they built that
ending al Motown yeah
[Music]
hated up on so much after that like I
mean he he wasn't you know he was a
translator he wasn't meant for that yeah
but he was literally down the stairs
stuff what's funny is like that the guy
let him live but it's because he helped
him in a way well if you know like he
owed him one right like he was just like
all right yeah like you putting a like
looked out for me before and I guess
I'll let you slide this time I think the
other part too was he was just he just
wasn't a threat yeah he was like all
right whatever
like I'm not dirtying my knife on this
guy he barely even looks at him alright
yeah so like I will say to kind of echo
what you did having a wait about a
minute or two to just get into the like
bay like the or the hangar rather it's
such a van loaded again is kind of a
little much that's such honestly that's
the problem my opinion like but that is
the fundamental like feature of a battle
royale is getting you into a match ASAP
right like even about apex like nail gun
yeah this thing takes forever to [ __ ]
dude I'll give you props if you kill
this guy but if it's like the Golden Gun
it has this damn reload animation that's
cute you know what everyone should start
off with this they should just give
everyone one of these a standard issue
pea shooter you know and then if you get
a kill you earned it right because look
how long it takes to reload yeah yeah
why are there so many be ours is it's
the trend for sure I really thought
Robert to be honest that we weren't
gonna get another one after blackout
other that when you fought about
firestorm but I thought that you know
the last kind of like real hurrah would
have been like you know battlefield give
me a go Cod giving it a go but we won't
be hold it for sure like apex just comes
out I agree well our all into it
I mean fad fads move Bad's move
quick right but the problem is that
games development takes a while like you
think about apex is the Dove said they
like they were make they started making
or you know experimenting with the BR
right when pub G was was it was
seventeen he said it was like it was it
was like very soon after time fell to
came out so that was that would be that
would be like if title two came out in
October or November sand then that would
be like think about pub G he was like
March right like am I right on that when
did it yeah I think so
we're like I remember like early of 2008
team right or sorry what again was
window I'm John Bing by the way okay
good
I forget exact date but yeah but anyways
yeah so like you think about it just
like you could say the same for black
out just was in development uh yeah
probably like a year and a half to two
years right I mean this is now says tell
Rob I wish him the best
thank you crying I'm just gonna landing
my buds play okay no you have a full
squad for now which is good oh it's the
first one we only have three and then
last one you only had yourself so you
know we're moving on up this looks like
a pretty good drop area a little Depot
or something there's a lot of a go to
the other building behind you because
those guys are looting that one the one
you want to go to you know just want to
be with my squad I don't want to tire we
got striker
over there little little level three I
like it dispatch sniper oh yeah Oh some
guy got level two armored ID maybe these
guys know the hot spots you know is this
the equivalent of like the Arab I'm
guessing okay so here's another question
for chat for those playing have you guys
found that certain areas yield like high
loot mid loot kind of stuff or is it all
randomized
come on daddy needs a new um Panzerfaust
okay use that last game thanks a lot
game yep
artillery strike wasn't enough man oh I
would have I would have had that tank
for sure if I like swap to this pounds
of fast finish them off done dude you're
done with an SMG and rep no I don't
rifle in the rent sniper damn well
what's that oh is that knife no I don't
worry about it
all right I think this building is out I
was check out some supposed to run out
that window
yeah I thought I was like do it and I
was like wait no there's fall damage
yeah like still good like still in one
piece oh my guys are ahead huh Tom Brown
says I couldn't get any loot before I
died twice yeah it's probably word I
don't know maybe bad luck in terms of
like drop or maybe just you happen to
drop in spicy or something hard to say
purple it's better than green it looks
like it or pink purple so it's green
blue pink purple
there's probably gold I would imagine
right chat help me out tell me if
there's a tier above the pink purple
it's not very purple it's more maroon
maroon RL calmer well level the blue
pawns a house Faust Faust pawns of Faust
interesting that it keeps both tiers
C's he'll like I remember that says
pistol ammo
how far you boys they're kind of far I
should just go with him huh yeah Thomas
is probably bad luck oh there's no gold
okay
so it just stops at the maroonish color
then get to bamboozling just been
bamboozled yes there is gold says Greg
TV I don't know
crimes always here and he doesn't lie to
me but I Greg's new and I don't doesn't
matter where you go the loot will be the
same oh okay
Greg TV seems pretty legit to drop in
solo for squad good times that sounds
tough gold is the rarest yeah I would
imagine if there is you know what's that
noise that's her that's our guys is it
yeah they're in a car that little whip
standeth a clean whip well there's a
knight-errant
there honking like hey get in the GD car
don't you dare let leave you oh it's
only a two persons all right here right
over okay fine it's behind you but let's
see if it works don't yeah this worse
little convoy action v1 is gold oh damn
we need a v1 it's funny when we did the
battlefield 5 shooting all we do all we
wanted was a v1 rocket and like only one
time did it ever hit anything you got
like a double kill though I think or a
triple kill off of it I'm just pretty
dope yeah this whip is sick man I know
right it's clean well Tom you can yeah
you can play a solo
no squads at least it's even that way
you don't get sad stay out of open area
yeah well you know when your teammates
kind of like drive off I kind of have to
just catch up to them right oh yeah
look
does that mean oh you jumped out
oh they're getting shot out I'm getting
shot at all right this is how you get
spice you just drive a car over oh you
got a sniper though right snipe ah look
at you
tactical you take kill nope yeah yeah
squad kill that's good assist where his
buddies though was it an insta oh we
should look at his butt do you think
it's like a loop box just find out
Oh catastrophic here troublemaker oh
great I know right cuz they just
datastreams everything heavy vehicle
ammo this is a perfect way to die
it really is we shooting here I hate
when people just fire randomly it's time
all right that guy must have level 2
armor because one of your boys just
swapped it there no I did he so then
what I can pick his [ __ ] up or someone
else - nah there's no other level to you
they just have little one if you want
spice has some Chili Peppers for life
that's true that's so true can you use
the tractor I don't know you're that
yeah is that you're a guy though
I think he's in a car oh wait is he yeah
he's in a car
dude he's got one like yours except it's
red damn that's way cooler okay you I
want in
you guys are ghost ride the whip oh look
at that look at that strategy oh I got
it
daddy's a gentleman I like is sick he
rolled back that is pretty sick he's
like I'll be on the top so why me
for some reason I got vibes of Saving
Private Ryan Ryan again we're barns or
Ed Burns character gets on that like um
what they call it that's rabid or
something like that oh yeah I know what
you're talking about but they learn they
learned the tanks and put to him oh he
fell off yeah I'm sure that didn't work
out hey it was a great idea till it
wasn't but still uh she's talking about
how she's trying to get you to finish
Twin Peaks yeah
oh all right you trying to get a supply
point here it looks like
did you drop gas to like cover fire or
it was that something I'm just broke I
didn't know someone else you should get
in the finger oh I saw flare go up Oh
someone got sniped [ __ ] till you strike
oh no watch out Rob I think they're
trying to do to you what you did to
someone else
yep I hear it good luck to our teammates
yeah that that animation isn't as cool
as I thought it would
artillery yeah Oh still going on but
maybe go try to revive your buddy
oh for sure damn aren't you playing
medic - I am yeah that's yes sir
I want him I got our way got out this is
me that's us
lifeline over here my am I using mine
don't worry it'll be okay
Oh 200 points BAM just died again we
want the points don't get sniped I think
they're behind you like the other way I
think they're that way yeah yeah this
way or the other
triage honors saved thank you
GeForce experience the firestorm has
started storms comin Annie wait did you
guys get the supply point I think you
did yeah yeah I think I think you've
finished holding it so hopefully there's
some good speed
I've been walking by these man oh really
I think though I think these are crates
I like oh no where are they at I don't
know I missed it feel like it's a sniper
oh my god are you okay snipers got
talent' boys oh my I did yell I guess
that's what it would be like to get
murked after you're like down our boys
what are we looking at alright well
they're running well we got promoted by
virtue of someone dying up there they're
squabbling
yes yes Rob I'm talking about
oh yeah selfie oh look at all his loot
he just spilled it all out Oh does he
have armor boys oh he had a syringe of
some sort oh yeah that purple STD oh
it's purple I don't have now is not a
good time your boys down to strike huh
not good
striker back up medic level three oh
right yep I like it I like I like it
Grenada smoker another actually breathe
oh [ __ ] oh that guy was accurate friend
you can do it Elise the axe is their
tool
you did he definitely did
all right I'm that's good poles total
squad kills no you got white squad white
yeah so there was two of them
how's my bad good we're a we're getting
better or you're getting better I'm
getting better at talking thanks GG all
the loots
ah yeah that's that tough balance do I
loot right now or some coming oh boy you
know what I forgot I forgot about this
game the shooting feels pretty good nice
you know mm-hmm you kind of liked it
yeah I did I just I'm I'm bad with
bullet drop and stuff like that yeah
yeah someone said don't move or keep
moving for sure I don't know I was more
trying to gauge where they were but
that's good advice I'll keep moving yeah
you're still like learning and adapting
to this style of Battle Royale
you know like we're coming off the backs
of playing a lot of apex and this is
definitely you know a different
experience so and kind of just like
relearning how to play battlefield in
general kind of like I haven't played
since when they first launched when I
was playing with you guys but yeah if
you get like I said earlier thanks for
tuning into GameSpot live live Monday to
Friday today we're checking out
firestorm battlefield fives battle
royale mode 64 player max some people
were saying earlier that it needs a
hundred maybe the map seems big enough
to support more players but I mean the
other part too is that like how many
people are actually playing this game
you know like I don't know what the
player like I mean you've been mostly
filling out except for one game so I
guess I'm getting at is like the speed
of which you're getting back into a
battle royale you know I mean like you
want a lush amount of Garcia's would you
say this game is equal better or worse
than black out I think it's different I
think most Cod players play cod in most
battlefield players play battlefield is
that fair - is that a fair statement or
do you think there's some crossover
because I've always been a cod player
personally so I really Bailey I think I
think you're on point I just wonder how
many people are like I mean that's
that's how you used to be right like a
lot of people were really gung-ho about
battlefield but I I
I think that this game is more akin to
like you know obviously playing a
battlefield game cuz it is a battlefield
game blackouts and cards in general are
more like I don't know you think it's
fair to say Arkady cuz it's like there's
not recoil really yeah you know you're
not really dealing with bullet drop the
vehicles in firestorm can actually do
stuff so you have tanks you have you
know jeeps and things like that with
turrets and things like that whereas
blackout like the vehicles are strictly
for traversal so it's different
obviously I think it just depends on you
know what you're into yeah Jimmy last
Aspire storm really necessary though I
mean they obviously had it as part of
their plan when they released
battlefield you know as Robin mentioned
earlier the hot fad right now is battle
Royales or you know at least a year ago
they were right so probably wanted to
test the waters probably want to to have
it you know as a multiplayer experience
and it seems to be like pretty good from
what I've seen like for what like if you
like battlefield I could see like if I
played a lot battlefield I would be
interested in this mode right it's
different than in some ways then you're
just traditional battlefield you're more
like you're forced for members
potentially against you know a bunch of
other people trying to get to you know
to the end to try to try to get a
victory yeah but this this is what
bothers us I think this it feels like a
natural fit like I remember when you
know Cod and bath filled all announced
they were doing battle royale like I
mean I was more stoked for battlefield
steak on it oh nice oh yes a mouse
movement was cuz this is freaking taking
forever yeah
freaking oh sweet try again this just
seems a little too late says Tom Brown
but I guess it's okay yeah I mean as Rob
said game development takes time you
know they could have realized you know
like last year or maybe like a little
bit before last year as their
development like oh you know what be
really cool let's try to get a battle
royale in here right like I don't know
how soon they think about that and how
like you know how long this takes but
obviously it took some time because it
wasn't
when the game shipped right so do you
think battle-ready always say
battlefield 5 that's hard for me to
answer I don't I think there that it's
interesting but I don't know how many
people will like continue to play and
stick with it
I think it's you're mainly looking at
the battlefield demographic I don't know
how much it's gonna pool other battle
royale players in I guess I think people
who have who have purchased the game it
brings some reason to come back right
mm-hmm dude oh you just lost your whole
squad somehow you can just do solos if
you want but I don't know
then I'm gonna work you have to cancel
out of you
so let's see okay this still takes two
minutes so I don't know I guess grab a
sandwich go to the bathroom in between
games I'd rather do squads yeah that's
fair yeah so yeah my one critique
without just gameplay as Robin mentioned
earlier too is just the low time
in-between games is pretty painful just
one here trying to find a squad to play
with and then actually getting into the
hangar and waiting waiting again so
[Music]
interesting
oh so once their squad leader they have
to hit it that seems like oh that seems
excessive
what like who would want so you're now
in the hands of that person
I guess the squad leader can just drop
if there's like two three people in if
he wants he or she wants that's pretty
yeah Anthony ring so good battlefield
tends to stick more to realism yeah hey
can you start the game that like that's
why ok Higgins says go back to the wall
if this doesn't work he says go back to
the homepage then back again I know go
straight in fast I had this earlier but
I mean I don't know if you want to leave
this squad now that you have a squad
yeah unlimited healing super realistic
it's okay Rob patience is a virtue
this will train you for SEC euro you
definitely will need some patience for
Sakura so this is good yeah I didn't
have any last night when I was blowing
that's for sure
Oh what was that
I sounded like a good noise or did it
was that a good yeah 6x6 a hint scavenge
and survive search for weapons outrun
the fire storm and battle other squads
Oh daily orders wait did we end up only
with two oh we lost one whatever maybe
we lost maybe you lost two lovely crack
okay so three person squad that's fine
better and then solo squad you make them
do that I think the twitchy I think the
one eye twitch look like there it is the
one eye that's gonna hurt happy birthday
you like it hello how does it feel are
you okay
got him Seki reals prequel yeah I have a
love-hate relationship with the game I
still personally think blood-borne is
better but whatever that's my own
personal opinion I have beat SEC euro
twice though I got the crap ending and
then I got a ok I think I'm getting an
okay ending you gotta wait a whole other
minute in here it's ok Rob you can go
shoot people go shoot people they don't
die Eric yeah well you can at least
figure out your recoil patterns you know
maybe practice that jump the jump Crouch
run things I try I was trying to I don't
know I think crime is lying to us oh
dang liar says do you think firestorm
will get more people to buy BFI ooh I
don't know about that I think that it's
more for the people that already play
battlefield to be honest
Higgins really likes firestorm wants our
thoughts on it but he or she prefers
solo mode what are your thoughts so far
from the game thoughts are I need to
keep playing yeah Michael in the chat
brings up a good point says dogs are
cool it's been I can't I can't dispute
that I'm a dog person myself and I'm a
dog um I think that it's interesting I
think that it at least has differences
that sets it apart from other be ours
while still keeping some of the you know
traditional be our aspects but I haven't
seen enough to make a really good
opinion and I again on a personal thing
I just never gravitated towards
battlefield so it's hard for me to like
get into it too much it'd be so funny if
they had planes in this I'm not lying
you're not sliding while in the air
that's kind of cool though that there's
no you're lying crime mechanic thingy
all right this barn is mine come in hot
yeah yeah quickly quickly oh man we're
getting so good at it now look at this
we're like a vacuum cleaner it's like
Sakura Oh medium armor that get hype so
the media markets are you ready yeah
yeah oh he's getting shot dude oh [ __ ]
we dropped spicy but the good news is
you have armor were you mad dude who you
shooting at no someone was shooting
danger yeah what do you have a shotgun
shotgun and pistol best combo B skip
over here oh yes enemy down hey girl
okay there's another person okay oh
you're so you got your other squad mate
joined somehow what there's got to be
more people right repair your armor oh
that's great right are we gonna test
this theory whoa oh yeah I nailed it
yeah so you can't open whoa
after you should repair your arm one
more time by the way oh oh you didn't
have any sorry yeah didn't notice that
it's okay I forgive you damn it needs
heals all right so they only had two is
that what it was
or they're the rest of their team and
drop with them maybe hanging out spicy
yeah gotta find some health that was
tight oh you look like you got some
sticky grenades too I think oh you're
right I do need to call good call good
call you're using the Force to heal them
yeah it seems that way I don't look up
here little little head Serendip okay so
it's a it's a heal over time this is
better than my secondary which is
interesting cuz I guess you're not
spending time actually healing it like
medkit over here Mobius I don't have a
pistol on I can't pick it up you have
one it says does it not know I don't
know oh you know maybe you don't have
backpack yeah
that's my guess my theory don't get near
to down person cuz even if they don't
have a gun they can still knife you uh
all right so it's like martyrdom there
are not martyrdom last minute less
whatever you last standing final stand
no Saturday what's up harm OD oh is that
supply point so they're not okay
hi would you like a grenade one grenade
well is a sticky you should have picked
it up because you already had sticky I
did pick it up I mean like I tried to at
least that's fine whatever maybe I can
only carry two Aaron said something
about sliding mean different PC maybe
it's like double tap Crouch just to try
to slide try to just slide how do you
slide okay so you need to do that wall
midair is what he's saying I know final
stand okay oh it's not crowd a lot yes
it's prone look at that yeah is that
really hoping I feel like it's about the
same you want to drop heels for your
buddy's shop a couple syringes then you
have seven right
Bing it yes hey you need some health
Oh your are you gonna are more plating
things oh no I think you just have to
swab it probably dude you better take
flying okay oh how dare you someone
somebody will kick it out one of those
yeah five it's ok yes I'm the spirit oh
they're just muting this guys are ahead
of us huh I like it there they're after
they they looted that yeah you want to
pick up their scraps oh they've left arm
where I think I know they pick this up
allied yeah see oh it's a flare gun
yeah I gotten Oh ping it ping it
yeah medium armor come on boys there's
medium armor here how do they miss that
it's slide not prone you're still not
doing it subscribe we'll try the
advanced tactics later let's just oh
dang but you have to do it while
sprinting oh ok maybe hold the Crouch Oh
teammates down
hallo squid TV oh yeah yeah let's go
crack let's go oh they're both down way
to go
teammates that I okay one guys just dead
or quit the other guy quit - come on we
could have got there
I'm the squad leader err those two must
have been buddies they're like these
guys aren't coming do you like at some
point we should get out no I dude you
got a dual turret yeah but this is my
range this is my mic right there he ran
and you ran into him over
oh yeah look at this Bangalore movement
get rekt Rob cats on the scene got
level-2 armor I'm just a hide man I
think I heard footsteps
you get rekt - oh God we're on fire oh
this this is intense that fire is so
intelligent hurt that bad though
it's it's level one fire that's tight
alright be healed bar in there yes I'm
talking about pop another one little
other ways you can't it's on cooldown
alright cool do you have armour plating
things I don't think so
and we didn't get to loot those guys
feel bad also it sucks that you'll have
armor bits to use and you crack where
are you taking us we need loot crack
Cola - oh you wanna keep going I thought
your sobbing sorry I don't know I think
this guy needs to like I don't know what
he wants we want to leave I need to get
armor and that guy needs to heal
oh you're getting shot I don't like it I
said that sounds like a tank
what do you think about that I don't
know I you would know better than me
don't worry we spotted him Oh
serpentine believe it Rob
you can solo in this I believe in you oh
yeah they can't hit oh look at my mat
and my mini-map do you see the old dam
he's got three on the chase we're gonna
outmaneuver him do you run faster while
your guns are stowed people oh no I was
thinking I should just sniper that's
cool I'm having fun are you having fun
hey man you got two kills level two
armored why not I know I mean you guys
were just in a crappy position dude had
to book it though maybe you're getting
out that one time cause I'm just saying
I don't jump out I don't like cars yeah
but the cars were chasing you you know
there was another car chasing us are you
saying no I'm saying that group must
have been in a car hmm to some degree or
something I don't know I could be wrong
I'm always right someone says I love how
the healing animation is you wanting to
give a high-five
oh you mean the revive no it's more like
hey hey Oh subscribe guys go mice no
well we do have a mic
mehar d hi um wait what was that hi um
there's no no no no no I just was being
a bad joke about how we have a Mike like
Mike Ohio oh no again alright I like
that let's go check it's not good once I
had to explain I don't think you can run
faster having tried bringing knife maybe
well with knife
hey that wasn't that bad that load yeah
no but now we have another loading we
could always so try the other thing that
someone mentioned today I think Higgins
he's like back out back out that sounds
so dumb but we should try it you never
know you never know you can slide by
pressing Crouch two times very fast the
jump is to cancel the cool down so you
can keep sliding oh my god it's so hard
to do the Crouch I have to like change
my key binding then
like you know where we got a twitch
player twitch yukio are they tried
looking down while running oh I've heard
that oh my what that's so weird because
I kept my fov - hey look a look looks
like I still like it's like you're you
don't have a spine or something
oh no why Rob let's go dude
I'm gonna kill your dumb ass oh damn we
need to mute that guy real fast
Ron Swanson says I got I got I got to
keep my I got to keep my armored cats
like an apex well if I had armor to
begin to you didn't have armor oh you
know what I'm noticing the circle like
the map is changing every time like now
there's more snow let's go to let's go
skiing
okay oh they're all saying they're one
of those guys those like YouTube guys
know suang
oh damn
because there's a damn
nice
I'll follow this guy
I hear gunshots sounds good
let's get spicy I like a despise how
quickly I can pick things up stay key
left our squad I like that name was that
the guy the cool guy that was like like
drop the other guy's name is named who a
mine the guy's name is a twitch TV Yukio
you didn't repair you don't have sick
you're sick there's enemies over there
can you ping it okay oh yeah I'm cool
enemies gonna cross the bridge I [ __ ]
up we said no swearing surprise from mr.
president suppressor you suppressor and
like give him
movement oh just like Saving Private
Ryan tell me a Bible verse oh he's
trying to revive us it's great I got one
nice we done one blue we done one coming
up blue
you're my boy push up push up the phone
book yeah they're falling back cuz
they're trying to revive below
oh he's thirsty don't do that I see that
guy was looking at the other what you
get for looting no I need a shotgun
gonna SMG Denny no dang can you respond
I not right I didn't know anything that
was it I mean F damn almost got a sick
headshot though Thanks
I think we have time for all depends on
how fast it goes I'd say one more but it
depends on them how it goes
Brandon's not a fan of this mode no
commend the guy he's fun yeah I think I
was cool I mean other than swearing but
you know that's funny
this mode is awful Brandon come on it's
not better luck next time senpai because
he died with this MP this MP GG well
played any wins yet no we played like
five games I think if you want to see a
squad win go to the youtubes I think
they would do it in the his preview
gotta a squad yeah if you want to see
good gameplay just exit out this video
no you're doing fine you got a headshot
I would have missed every one of those
shots did you remember that first
blackout stream I did I like had a
sniper rifle and I could not for the
life of me hit anything it's like me
with a wingman wingman over here but
dude when you hit the wingman shots it's
like mm but then when you miss it's like
actually don't like ice fgz apex I'm
about the AR life all about the 301 the
trio one man are the cheat codes here
okay did you get it yep
okay cool infinite health is what I
entered alright that the whole weapons
games seem to be loading a little bit
all you're by yourself right now
guess that means my pains hella good
what's up well we're dropping spicy oh
did you get to see the snow no never got
to see that snow okay hopefully we get
some snow
just fix this box here nice nice nice
that's what's up oh yeah yeah you guys
like catch me if you can
yeah maybe this is a good time to
practice the the old slide dude it I
have to I would have to change my hotkey
to like you're saying to tell you to do
the slide in the air right to cancel the
that what they're saying but the thing
is is like it's just awkward keys almost
I wonder how much time that actually
says it almost I heard I heard the
animation go try to find a tank can ya a
tank would be cool yeah ages piss got a
3-game three kill game but then server
drop oh I know that is I know that feels
Oh a CJ I don't know about that you
should try it if you like battlefield I
think it does interesting thing hi
that's so weird
it's like your backs like you have no
spine anyways I think if they add some
its I think it's interesting what PT
right now
will you please try this game on
consoles soon PC looks dead
really I don't know what games
let's go ski let's go to Pluto I mean
can't you just treat it that way
grease man just think of it that way for
yourself and then play it right like why
not are you gonna smell sick so you can
definitely go fantastic fantastic
that's cool I don't need any teammates
we're a lone wolf you're the old [ __ ]
coming on
yeah Jen Roger brings up a good point oh
it's about to get spicy ladies and
gentlemen we should run there the whole
squad bro
is there a tactic to dropping faster oh
sorry I robbed you and him
Oh No okay okay not the worst Oh
actually kind of the worst Oh medium
armor though oh this guy's toast rob go
teach him something teach him not to
mess around parties with the old Rob cat
yeah now we're dead because you have no
armor bit oh do you use armor just right
there oh and heels
let me just hang out here for a hot
second Oh guys I'm coming in I don't
know I didn't see anything
I'm looking at you healing yeah she
crouched there's definitely two to your
left but I don't know how far that yeah
there were there ever in that like pit
right like whatever the area was called
oh he's got a blue STG demo
sick Oh let's party dude it's a party
dude on Monday that's crazy I know right
who parties out of Monday only crazy
people
oh we're there oh we cracked your armor
that's unfortunate what you did he's not
dead come on that's a rocket to your
face four more no definitely one more he
should be dead you see how much damage
did anyone know I did once I did the
rocket anyone yeah 121 that's why he has
like no life left but still come on I'll
rock it to the face rock on I don't feel
going for realism yeah I thought this
game was realistic come on come on
and such thanks Alan
it says we'll play well well that's nice
I pushed that let's do this tactic back
out see well back out and now we'll get
in quicker boom instant oh you did get a
squad right away but you're not the
authorized to squad leader so you know
unfortunate that medium armor armor was
clutch to saved you for sure yeah from
my first guy that guy had armor too
though yeah at least I love one armor so
it's pretty pretty close knew those
things I bet he saw me almost like high
five no but when I that that building
was very long and I feel like he saw me
like on every window coming up like he
knew I was coming in I could have
crouched I was the attach as I was
running and I was like I should have
probably like snuck in it's alright man
you were not afraid you're like let's
throw hands here which I see the game
has fall damage I know it has fall
damage yes why we haven't parachutes
Southern moment where Robert was that a
third storey buildings like probably not
probably not where's the Shire yeah I
know right
dip dodge duck the 5b
oh you don't dip dodge and duck it oh
that is rich
come on
I really wish they what like why don't
they let you mess with your our marine
your and your in your camp or company oh
you mean just kind of like have
something to do Oh wouldn't it be love
me was there your dirty are you serious
is so funny it says goose thanks goose
tactical bagpipes
you can cancel fall damage by deploying
parachute at last second its redeploy
able like in the base game can you do it
from a building though I mean it's got
you got to have some time to pull that
shoot you know you can't just jump out
of one-story building you know I got ya
it's not gonna deploy quick and get all
these tips TM hot tips alright this is
it this is the wind what if I want dude
dude I believe you had to believe it men
you know but he wants to have more stuff
to do while waiting unless you can back
out without losing your position yeah
yeah I mean like you think about like I
mean apex have it has it a lot of games
have it but overwatch while you're in
key missed out the other stuff you
couldn't possibly it could possibly
still load while you're like in the
menus
hey you got your dad gosh so much blood
your dad
double kill you can't do everything
while waiting for a triple what are you
talking about
don't miss quad quad damage well I'm
outta ammo knife um oh man this is a
long longest kill streak ever did oh
crap oh there's Easter eggs in this
loading area Oh like what tell us don't
too late now we'll never like what crime
oh so maybe a cert then yeah then that
then maybe I'm wrong Lily and well then
they shot I mean always got our back it
should be should be more present are you
going to the Arctic at Lake oh we're
going back to the snow going back back
to Pluto Pluto wait where did your
teammate drop too hopefully he's going
for that no they're all going here let's
do it oh wait wait what were that were
they going sorry I changed my mind
I hope you make that ain't pretty bushes
sound sage advice all right so there's a
supply point oh boy we're late they're
changing yeah they're changing it up all
right let's go here oh go to that house
again just go there to your right
oh sure yeah is that there's some loot
at least you know it looks like a
lootable area to me so at least I got
you a shot good your favorite
I do like shot ease shot emo body
there's hitting cans all over and people
think we shoot them and order something
will happen
Oh
machine gun scooty McGee I'll just don't
die already yep
yeah the right guy did he won and he
went into the area that uh possum maybe
he shouldn't have that where do you go
we we land in the dry
these guys are handed last minute yeah
all right sorry
it was nothing
[Music]
wait a second you can't get rid of them
yeah that's crap Molotov cocktails hello
Molly Molly Molly they show that sick
ball damage actually get those heels
first now so good
the only two-story building our legs are
durable we don't skip leg day hair games
why we're not testing flare gun
sure oh what a backpack that's why yeah
making a ruckus
huh yeah oh let's party oh you drop
there's a backpack oh there you go
it's time to party more storage that's
all I can carry I guess should I ditch
this machine gun I don't know Oh what
was that one is that different flare gun
they had like a little supply a care
package Oh care package try pop it I
dare you oh damn bring the party to you
so I have to equip it right swap it so
with the the artillery doesn't alright
that works
alright let's party let's party don't
make sure you yeah
I was like don't call in the artillery
Shere Khan accident and kill yourself
that's these guys are far away show you
do it yeah let's do it
this is when I'm defending this area
Tyler says watching from work can't wait
to get home to play nice thanks for
stopping by and tuning in
I shouldn't have this means I think it's
still a different style of play like I
don't I mean I gravitate more towards
the apex gameplay but that's just me
little little box
oh god that scared me ok ok ok ok gotta
be quick gotta be quick did you just get
another one from the same thing I got a
half track oh sorry I thought you got
like a oh that's cool we should call
that it is that a Liefeld oh I'm taking
this I don't know if I want to shock
them so I'm gonna ditch shotgun ammo
well I mean don't stay there too long
before we're gonna come after you okay
let's do it and then calling your little
thing later a little vehicle try do it
now
why can't i donate uh you guys tuning in
is basically like doning so we
appreciate it
feeling real sick and now at work I
don't wanna get anyone else sick I think
I gotta go home pop I think I got the
black lung Oh see you guys tomorrow god
they are far so kind a vehicle ooh I
like that site that's way easier to see
than the other gun that you had earlier
or maybe it's just like a different
scope high voltage can't wait to play
this game mode sick wait for reals where
is my team okay they're in a tank or
something right
Oh what yeah no sorry now a little green
plus I made me think he was now but he's
a medic
Derek silly goose man is Josh not found
any armor yet
no area is cool yeah like here in Tahoe
straight up dude let's get some fresh
fresh powder and shred the gnar Samurai
gecko is out today actually check it out
if you want thing here's my this needs a
ring of Elysium boarding maybe skis
there is skiing in the single-player
cool if you could have it here I would
give you a shout out salty but I can't
see the road they wonder if they took
this I can't say the rest of your name
because you know obvious reasons if you
have the game then you have it but it's
not free so it's part of battlefield 5 I
swear is he in a tank
what am I just seeing no he's in like a
half boy they just love eluded that
house should i this is our last game
sounds like a fun idea though alright
one on the hill and one in there yeah
whatever
oh he's right in front of you at the
yellow house there in that yellow house
right now yes
please let it land come on
store the house oh [ __ ] we're just
trying to watch an air strike I will
never get to see well no it will never
know you slide down this hill Oh got one
who cut to Dan we couldn't walk where
what did he whatever it was the perfect
cigar
yo cool guys look away from explosions
Eric plus I was being shot at and I want
to be able my buds why aren't you
calling you're a little thing to drive
to them they're shooting they're
fighting oh one guy is dead already
and gone he left sounds like someone's
running right behind me look at the
destruction I wanted him to crime but he
freaked out when he got shot at which is
fair but I would've did it for chat I
would have died
Oh horrible death hindsight 360 I'm up
I'm up
oh good the call [ __ ] if you're gonna
engage at least give yourself a fighting
chance nope nope oh it's for sorry guys
oh I'm super good well you did get a
double-double shake Eric bathroom how
dare you crime how dare you I I laid it
I laid the foundation I laid the scene I
said they're in the house drop the
artillery strike we just didn't get to
see the finale okay we didn't get to see
fin
it really needs to be a hundred players
a map is too huge
your friend dude I don't I haven't
played enough to know kind of think it
depends on the firestorm and stuff like
that which I use this go ahead you have
eight of them there's 64 players in a
match oh my god dude name we could have
saw the explosion and we still wouldn't
we still would have got the same thing
happened guys it's easy when you're not
the one playing are you death saved
thanks and video all saved let's see if
scooty McGee gets a little okay he's
doing the right thing he's camping the
stairs he's like you can't get off these
stairs
oh he's throwing gas because he thinks
it's good English but they're not okay
yeah hey I'm over here
oh he's gonna make a big play here big
place did you get him
I don't think you got him oh oh he's
toast because he's finding a SMG with a
shotgun
oh I lied another guy another guy
another guy well should we call it call
it yeah we should call it anyway should
call it well that was fun check out
firestorm battlefields Battle Royale
it's out today if you own the game it's
not free so you have to have battlefield
5 but the update itself is out thanks
Rob for playing of course whitney says
explosions are overrated
yes don't defend him chat wanted to see
the explosions campers will camp well I
wasn't really camping they came and
pushed ya thoughts Rob from your you
know right now I've been rocky playing I
wanna play some more
nice I don't know there's also a game
called apex I want to play as well I
probably like to be honest I probably
won't hop on I've never been a huge
battlefield fan if I'm gonna play battle
royale
nope a play apex also just because I've
been playing SEC euro so I have two
games already I can't really entertain a
third I just don't have a for sure
variety I mean if you got battle
battlefield 5 I don't see why you
wouldn't come back to check oh yeah if I
had battlefield 5 and I play it you know
either even if I don't play consistently
I think I would check out this mode just
to try it out it does have differences
and I don't know there's something about
the Battle Royale it's pretty fun you
know like those there are those moments
that you can have that you might not
experience in any other game like you
know when you get through those final
couple squad situations I don't know I
think it's cool
I do too I do too alright come back
tomorrow we'll be back at 11 a.m.
Pacific Standard Time for more streams
we appreciate everyone coming out hit
subscribe if you have it to get notified
so that uh you can join us and hang out
we really appreciate it
see you later happy Monday bye